[Music]
hello fortnite family and welcome to
playstation grenade
it's now week three of chapter two
season five of fortnite battle royale
and this week we have a little update to
run you through if you don't know
this is the series which looks at the
map changes and secrets on the island
and then applies them to the story of
fortnite to predict
the future so sit your butt down for 10
minutes slap code adamara in the store
to support this three-year-old project
and let's dive into week three
the first thing i noticed after the
update is that there is a new npc to be
found
there are now 41 of these to find how
many of you got so far
the new npc is the snow mando so you can
guess where you find this guy he's near
catty corner up by the snow cone truck
on the snowy mountains
by talking to him it's possible to
obtain a returning weapon we get every
december
the snowball rocket launcher now named
the big
chill exotic i couldn't afford to buy it
to showcase it right now but rest
assured it operates just like it did
back when we first saw this
in december 2017. yep that's three years
ago
feeling old yet also whilst we're up
here do these green areas in the snow
mean anything
i'm so confused by them was something
here previously that made these marks
or is something incoming i'll be sure to
keep an eye on them
and let you know in fact there is one
more thing up in the snow that we should
take a look at
many of you got in touch and told me
about this last week over in the weather
station
is a brand new item and it's like no
other before it
an indestructible book turns out a chap
named cipher pk
asked for this book as a sign that the
developers were listening to the
community
and i guess they sure are cipher has a
series which helps people improve at the
game
and this represents his playbook my
challenge to you this week
is to get your butt to that book and see
if you can make it stand on its edge
there is literally no reason to do this
but i'll be sure to retweet
whoever does it first before we move on
to the christmas side of the update i
first wanted to make sure the
mandalorian was okay and if the razor
crest had been fixed up yet
it hadn't but i also noticed one of the
greatest little details of the season
it's possible to track mando's
footprints here how cool is that it
leads to his original campsite
but holy grogu the campsite has vanished
and so has mando i looked around and
found this is the way to him
if he got that joke well done his new
campsite is west of the coliseum and he
now walks much further away from his
spawn zone
i got lucky here he had a stormtrooper
aim also i think we should highlight
this
he's cooking a meal by fire good to see
that someone is cooking the fish rather
than just straight up eating them raw
[Music]
now let's talk about crimbo we're about
to reach the time of the year where epic
do all their cool stuff
remember last year there was an ice
block factory which appeared by the
docks
i checked this week it's not there yet
but they put so much effort into that
last year that i do think it will return
other things that have returned are the
usual decorations around the pois
some houses getting the christmas vibe a
few weeks earlier than their neighbours
and then as we get closer to christmas
on the 25th more houses take part
my current fave is in retail row looking
good
retail is also the place the christmas
trees are found and are being sold to
the other pois
and if you kept an eye out last week
you'll have noticed that the tree
nursery by the dam
has had its trees all cut down the
yearly cycle continues
we expect flatbed trucks to transport
the krimbo trees over the island over
the next week
as i'm writing this there's only nine
days till christmas i haven't bought one
christmas present yet
the keen eyed amongst you will also note
that the reboot vans have moved in many
places
not all of them but in lazy and slurpy
those
vans have moved to make space for the
christmas trees
going back to retail for a moment i
think a mistake may have been made this
update
last week the christmas store appeared
as usual
we tend to see this build up over the
weeks in december
but this time it's just gone again i
don't think this is on purpose so once
again expect this to reappear
very soon and hopefully it will bring
back the misfit bear inside
for the last two christmases we've had a
misfit bear update which led
to a new storyline let's hope that
continues and let's do the thing now
hud watch update um nothing
unless i'm not seeing something i don't
think there's an update to hot watch
please correct me if i'm wrong
going over to ferris bueller's house
which has the fake john wicken site
this gaff has been updated to advertise
the new season of
rocket league the layout is almost
identical to the last time around it was
here but with the number two instead
big brain ad campaign there ggs the
coolest thing in the house is the return
of the rocket league car
it's back to cruise around the streets
and like usual
i can't drive it never get in a car with
me
in in game or irl so over the past two
weeks you guys have all been flexing on
me
with the sheer amount of easter eggs
you've seen pop up through those ground
elevators
with the i o troops on board you've seen
the rock dog you've seen the bromance
you've seen
midas's chair some of you have seen the
easter island head
well i haven't seen any of these at all
and i've seen about 300 of these
elevators lift up
but today i got one and it's a new
easter egg
whilst passing through pleasant the io
elevator sprang up
and christmas themed goodies were inside
another absolutely fantastic touch
fortnite devs
and just in case a fortnight dev is
listening right now
how about putting my pink guitar in one
of these elevators
and allowing people to interact with it
and wear it for the rest of the game
what do you think devs if i have to beg
i will
[Music]
upon my travels i looked more in depth
at the pois of the new npcs
and this island north of the map all by
itself that caught my eye
it's the same one that has the
telescopes in bushes it's someplace not
to be trusted
the npc there is a little fixated on
explosives
they are everywhere here but the main
nuke on show
looks to be something completely new a
new asset in fortnite
we've seen a few before don't get me
wrong mainly the glider for tientina but
i feel this item and others around the
map
are here for the main story arc and
we're missing a way to tie these
together
but saying that i picked up some maple
syrup in a game today
this theory needs some more work but i
do have a theory which i think i can
throw your way now
as we know the io troops are under the
ground until the moment they jump
out could this new mechanic link into
those
bunkers we've been looking at for years
the hatch is in the ground hidden at
three areas on the island
if you think about it if they can come
up then why can't we go
down if you want to have a look at the
hatches they are found under a bush near
retail row there's one at the island we
were just on underneath the hut
and the final one which i really do
think is the real one is under the sea
on the left of the island
it could be something could be nothing
but for those of us who like narrative
this is something to think on now over
to stealthy stronghold
last time we met i suggested this was a
jurassic park reference
and i still believe that to be true but
since then
other easter eggs have been found the
current theory which i agree with is
that there is
potential for a predator crossover this
is because there is a small town
in this poi which almost completely
resembles that in the movie predator
there's a vehicle set up in the same way
arnie uses it in the movie
and the final mind-blowing moment was
the helicopter hidden in the trees
just like in the movie it all adds up to
a 1980s movie crossover
that you may not care about but i
guarantee it will impress your dad
but only if he's cool and if he hasn't
gone to get milk three years ago
sorry to bring that up to compound all
this there is also a predator emblem on
the doors
again from the movie too this is almost
too perfect
to be wrong jonesy really wants the best
hunters in all realities
and the predator may be coming
[Music]
okay so next time we meet your lobby
screen will have changed to be something
more christmasy
and the event will officially begin
giving us the opportunity to earn new
items over the christmas period
thanks for your time i hope this was
useful and thank you so much to the
people who continue to use my code in
the store
i truly appreciate you i'm adam from
playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time